[Musik]
hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute meine damen und
herren zu einem neuen video auf einem
kanal und zwar zu einer nicht lachen
stellen weiter nicht lachen challenge
geht es darum dass man ja halt nicht
lacht und immer wenn ich lache muss ich
einen irgendwas zu trinken ich habe mir
extra solche irgendwas mit zitronen drin
gekauft sie sind richtig sauer und ich
würze angefangen direkt an
ok-chef
attacken hühnerfüße diesmal wird und die
acht gefährlichsten für dich und alle
[Musik]
bevor ich gleich den ersten in warschau
trinken will ich sagen hören uns
zumindest noch mal den witz an treffen
sich zwei jäger eine tot
[Gelächter]
reichlich
mein gott ich weiß ich aber dass auf der
kamera kennt weil der autofokus eben nur
um geschützt ist einfach so kleine
stückchen halten jedoch passieren so
dranhängt das sind einfach das sind
das sind irgendwas stückchen auf euch
und wenn du jetzt
wie katzenfleisch
das ist nicht wahr ich
war weder die scheiße da drum herum
schwimmen
das jahr
[Musik]
der erste war schlimmer
baustopp hier
ich hab nicht gedacht ich habe nur eine
frage am sonntag wird gesagt wir bauen
den flieger aus papier aber das ist
augenscheinlich kein papier dann ist ein
blatt
aber er hat der wille zählt dieses man
abschließt rief ich werde euch verlassen
nicht guten tag alle sind verblassen weg
auf so grausame welt es gibt keinen hält
jeder tag ist leicht wellig
da kriege ich auch ganz genau
jetzt netzwerk im vorfeld muss
ich finde es klasse wie viel mühe sich
leute dann mit ihren tipps geben gut ok
meiner tecdax sind auch nicht viel
besser
[Musik]
ich hab nicht gedacht
das kann nicht gut klappen das kann aber
das kann man nichts wäre
[Musik]
ich lag heute nicht mehr ich habe
richtig krasse laufwerken slate
[Musik]
auf jetzt muss etwas trinken das
ist schon so ekelhaft wie das da rein
schüttet guckt euch diese scheiße an
freundlich weiß ich aber dass er kenne
aber schon so viel kakophonie so mache
ich die teile oder so randvoll und man
auf die lupe
ah
ja den kenne ich schon der achte jetzt
mehr auf dem kopf schneller läuft weiter
den kenn ich glaube ich auch schon die
hat er rutscht aus
da kommt man schon erahnen die cup
tätige drauf die rutsche runter also ein
paar videos kenne ich jetzt tatsächlich
schauen aber das video ist eigentlich
relativ neu also die computer ist noch
nicht
das ist noch nicht das
haben wir auch irgendwas was ich das
kenne ich auch das sind alles nur sachen
die wir tun da lag ich ja nicht über ein
1 1
wie gesagt tut einfach nur weh das ist
doch nicht sein der sitzt doch keiner
von ihnen denkt sich
immer mal was sagt marco russ meine
coupé hier ja um eine brille oder das
ist obi ich bin es der schnellste rapper
von deutscher weiß nicht genau was du
nicht schreibt
das
ist die kraft
auf den lukas shop
ich wollte eigentlich ins klo kippen
aber ich habe dann doch noch
ausgestrahlt auf die leute das ist ich
habe es schon oft genug gezeigt in
diesem video aber schaut euch das an das
ist man denkt
was ein bisschen so wie wenn man durch
fall trinken erkennt ihr das wenn man
den beiden donnerstagen unterstellen wir
immer dunkel sind ungesund du machst
einfach für ungesund hier salat
gebe ich ihm recht oh
nein das weiß ich nicht das meint sie
nicht nein mein gott was habe ich
gelacht aber dass das war das erkennt
also ich trinke auf keinen fall nochmal
heute gab seien nicht auf radio und
mein gott du kannst doch dessen sehen
und herzlich auf die st
zunächst harmlos spielen ich wollte dich
mehr fragen möchtest du maine et net
sein freue mich auf antwort von dir
befüllt leute kennt ihr das wenn ihr
kein abo hat dann könnt ihr immer das
pflegen und so spielen mit freunden so
weit gehen
was'n live heute wenn ihr mal keinen
akku auf eurem handy haben sollte mega
gute taktik kauft euch einfach das pop
sorge die aus dem lukas ob da könnt ihr
dann einfach hier so dass die ganze zeit
so hoch und runter machen mega hammer
gibt zu kaufen
und apropos camino shop.de da gibt es
auch über diesen tollen die das ist ein
smiley und da vorne steht drauf werde
also dienst des
oder wenn ihr brennholz für den winter
braucht es auch gut geeignet oh mein
gott da kommt was relevanter gelaufen
wenn er im auto tritt liebe tod
mein gott das gibt auch ein video das
kann ich mir vielleicht finde ich das
mal kurz das jetzt auch so ein video wo
leute einfach mit ihrer karte direkt an
den löwen herfahren und dann kommt so
eine löwin hin und
schildkröten
[Musik]
ich habe den vorstand getrunken und im
mund gelassen so gehört weil der so
ekelhaft geschmeckt hat und dabei hab
ich den runtergeschluckt alles meine
nase
es ist für den ford mit etwas studieren
bei uns ist das so hier sind paten wir
sind aber auch beste freunde gleich sind
wir aber auch geschwister
[Musik]
vielleicht wird aus spaß und schott ganz
gut tun ich habe einfach ist
schweinefleisch gegessen
ist alles klar
[Musik]
das heute wieder ist alex aber ende
natürlich die freude wenn euch diesen
nicht lachen change gefallen hat und
wenn ich mich selbst darüber einen
daumen hoch von euch unter dem video
hier freundschaften wir 40.000 like das
wären mega krass und wird mir zeigen
euch gefallen diese nicht lachen
challenge ich kann gar nicht mehr
richtig reden weil mein hals voll mit
ingwer stückchen näher ist abonniert
allerdings auf jeden fall meinen kanal
falls sie noch kein teil der user das
ist kostenlos und verpasst keine videos
mehr und wenn ihr schon abonnent klickt
auch gerne auf die glocke denn dann
bekommt eine benachrichtigung sobald ich
ein neues video täglich hochladen
die fresse du lachen
[Musik]